sniper elite 5 the latest in rebellions
headshot in x-ray and shooter series is
upon us if this is your first sniper
elite game or you're a series veteran
here's everything you need to know about
sniper elite 5.
[Music]
the game takes place in 1944 at the apex
of the second world war the allies have
uncovered a secret nazi plot codenamed
project kraken which will turn the tide
of the war in the axis's favor playing
as u.s sniper carl fairburne once again
you'll head to war-torn france make
contact with the resistance troops
defending their homeland and take down
project kraken before it's too late
as it turns out kraken is a larger nazi
operation to attack america which would
have a huge negative impact on d-day
speaking of the events of the game take
place just before and just after d-day
with karl fairburne going into europe to
soften up enemy positions for the
planned invasion before uncovering and
getting swept up in this larger plot
in terms of gameplay yes you'll still be
shooting nazis in the head or other
places and get those gory x-ray kill
cams just like in previous sniper elite
games but the team at rebellion has made
a lot of tweaks and additions for the
fifth installment weapons have been
overhauled for the game and there are a
number of customization options
available for each they now all sport
iron sights that you can look through in
first person for example every level has
a number of workbenches that not only
unlock various attachments for your
weapons but also allow you to customize
them to your liking swap scopes barrels
mags ammo type and stocks to your
heart's content there are four stats
that are impacted by doing so power rate
of fire mobility and control rebellion
estimate that there are over 200 pieces
of weaponry to unlock meaning you can
tinker until you find the balance that
suits you best sniper elite 5 has a wide
range of classic world war ii weapons
like the m1903 springfield and the
carabiner 98 as well as experimental
prototypes including the srem1 enfield
bullpup sniper rifle and the bsa welgon
submachine gun not only does your weapon
matter when it comes to taking those
crucial shots but so do other factors
like wind gravity and carl's heart rate
sniper elite 5 is more intentionally
designed to encompass a range of
playstyles to encourage replayability
but the core gameplay loop remains the
same observe plan and execute during
missions you'll find secrets they can
shift your objectives or even open up
new routes and unlockable starting areas
higher difficulty levels like hard and
authentic change a lot of the game and
do things like add more bullet drop
reduce active reloading crank up the
impact of wind as well as reduce the hud
disable radar and turn off your ability
to zoom further when looking through a
scope and holding your breath
that should make you milsim enthusiasts
happy on the other side of things there
are a ton of accessibility options like
colorblind modes aim assist even with a
mouse and keyboard and text color
options to name just a few rebellion
worked with a number of british museums
including the imperial war museum and
the royal armouries hey that place
sounds familiar to capture reference
images of the weapons as well as record
the audio of them firing to ensure
they're as accurate to the real thing as
possible
when it comes to map size rebellion is
calling sniper elite 5's maps the
largest and most immersive in the series
history in order to help you get around
the huge spaces traversal has been
overhauled so carl can slide shimmy
climb and even zipline around to help
the maps become the quote most immersive
rebellion used a technique called
photogrammetry instead of an artist
modelling buildings from scratch
developers take hundreds of photographs
which are then fed into a program which
then spits out a 3d model that's then
cleaned up and put into the game the dev
team visited northern france including
locations like brittany normandy and
calais as well as examined sub-pens and
bunkers that were still left over from
world war ii i mentioned the killcam
earlier and yes it's back with rebellion
doing their darndest to make it the most
realistic version yet you'll still get
the grisly x-ray camera shots of bullets
passing through nazi skulls but now the
bullets can be deflected by bones
unpredictably and if getting the kill
cam with sniper rifles wasn't enough for
you smgs and pistols will also trigger
it as can knives and traps
if you want to get your buds in on the
action then have no fear you can tackle
sniper elite five in co-op the game even
has cross-play so it doesn't matter
which platform you're all on to
encourage teamwork you can give orders
to the other player share items and ammo
and even heal each other there's also a
co-op horde mode called survival where
you and up to three others can work
together to take out waves of enemies
teamwork truly does make the dream work
but if all that sounds a little too nice
for your liking maybe invasion mode will
be more up your street invasion mode is
exactly what it sounds like you drop
into another person's game taking on the
role of an axis sniper and can use the
in-game enemies to help you track down
the host player if you succeed you're
rewarded with weapons items and skin
unlocks if you manage to kill the host
player but the host isn't completely
vulnerable each level has a number of
invasion phones that you can use to find
the last known location of the invader
if you take out the invading sniper you
also get a number of rewards bear in
mind though you can turn invasion mode
off at any time but you will get more xp
for playing with it turned on
if you fancy some multiplayer there are
regular sniper elite multiplayer modes
like free-for-all team match and no
cross as well as a new 4v4 v4 v4 mode
called squad match other new additions
include items like decoys which you can
use to bamboozle enemy players into
thinking you're somewhere you aren't and
supply drops obviously they net you
great items but they also ping the
location of enemies in a 50 meter radius
so it's very important that you're the
one to get there first in previous
sniper elite games your multiplayer and
single player progression was shared but
now each has its own unlocks multiplayer
has its own perks that are not shared
with single player and these are split
between five different classes you can
then fine-tune each to your liking by
selecting perks and a secondary class
in terms of downloadable content sniper
elite 5 has a season pass that'll unlock
a bunch of extras including two campaign
missions two weapon skin packs two
character skin packs and six weapon
packs
sniper elite 5 will be coming to pretty
much every home console including
playstation 4 and 5 xbox one series s
and series x and will be available on
steam and the microsoft store if you're
an xbox game pass subscriber then the
standard version of the game will be
coming to the service on day one so
enjoy rebellion has revealed that there
are no concrete plans to bring the game
to the nintendo switch just yet but
sniper elite 4 did eventually make the
jump so fingers crossed its sequel will
do the same
sniper elite 5 is releasing on may 26th
and if you're after a physical copy then
your options are limited to playstation
and xbox only but there are a few
different bundles available depending on
the extras you're wanting the standard
edition retails at 59.99 on playstation
xbox and the windows store but is 10
cheaper if you grab it from the
rebellion shop or steam buying the pc
version from the rebellion shop also
bags you a digital graphic novel the
deluxe edition is 89.99 for playstation
xbox and windows store and 79.99 on the
rebellion shop and steam it comes with
the game season pass included as well as
the digital graphic novel if you get the
game from the rebellion shop speaking of
the rebellion shop also has a couple of
extra exclusive bundles if you're
looking to play on pc the cadet bundle
comes with a deluxe edition steam code
exclusive shirt graphic novel and
sticker for 99.99 and for 30 more you
can grab the marksman bundle which comes
with the deluxe edition for pc a bomber
jacket graphic novel enamel mug and
sticker pre-ordering any version of the
game nets you a bonus mission where you
kill hitler at his mountain retreat
berghoff and ap 1938 suppressed pistol
our very own aaron sampson went hands-on
with sniper elite five a couple of weeks
ago so make sure you check out this
video for his in-depth impressions on
how it's shaping up for more on sniper
relate five make sure you subscribe to
the channel and i'll catch you next time
[Music]